Okay, Godzilla
2150,
of course, it always has a very exciting
opening.
Players really like using G6. I mean, at
least
it's a bit dynamic. Yes,
of course there is, I've
seen B6 C5
do something directly here,
or is there four or so back then
four
well, there are
things that don't exist,
yes, it's a bit
unpleasant, well,
it can beat a knight, too, yes,
unpleasant, the position is
somehow unpleasant,
so E7 is still hanging on,
I can't think about it forever, of
course I can take E7 now, of course  But
you have to somehow
untie me here when he exchanges with them for that one,
so that this one comes into the game
is worth a pawn to me. I do
n't think he'll take it like that
if I take C4 now,
and now maybe
he's
hoping  then right now
I haven't seen it at all, I don't know if it's good, but I
just go back,
okay,
that's still a bit
uncomfortable
and, above all, I've been
thinking about it for ages
and somehow it looks
like it all the time  could someone be far away at some point
because it looks like that look spoon B7 or something like that
doesn't matter
maybe so
maybe you can get to C4
or knight A4 could maybe also
be relieved
funny figures on the A line all like that
the ceilings
time warning
yes my time
yes in terms of position  Now I think
the four are hanging and
the idea of ​​the whole action was
okay
in between, my quality was given,
it's not entirely clear what
I'm a lame duck for,
I actually had to easily win
it with three seconds